hey freunde was geht ab herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge von rolex trader projekt
mittlerweile folge vier krass wie
schnell die zeit vergeht
es werden wir das nicht mehr betreten in
der ersten folge haben wir eine 800 euro
mit reelbox gekauft in der wir 1700 euro
handy hatten mit dem gewinnt haben wir
eine viel zu riskante aktie gehebelt und
konnten so über 800 euro plus machen und
in der letzten folge habe insgesamt vier
pass nicht gekauft wir müssen uns jetzt
als erstes darum kümmern die alle zu
verkaufen und dann stehen wirklich
krasse release ist diese woche an bei
dem wir natürlich probieren alle schuhe
zu bekommen in der letzten folge gesagt
werde ich probiere mir ganz viele
accounts zu machen um möglichst seine
chancen zu erhöhen in den levels zu
gewinnen dass ein weiteres thema worum
wir uns kümmern müssen aber jetzt
verkaufen erst mal alles nieder und
probieren ein bisschen aus dem niesen
rauszukommen
ach ja und bevor das video losgeht ich
habe ein richtig fettes gewinnspiel für
euch die ehrenmänner von widmung von
sponsoren dieses video wieder und
verlosen fünf mal den jordan 1 mokka
einen der geheimnissen schuhe der auch
hauptthema in diesem video sein wird
zwar ein super verrücktes ja ich wurde
krass von euch support und so können wir
wenigstens an fünf leute was zurückgeben
insgesamt sind über 2000 euro wert und
wir müssen einfach nur auf den link in
der video beschreibung klicken euch die
app runterladen euch über den news tab
ins gewinnspiel eintragen und so nimmt
ihr müsst euch nicht in den app anmelden
oder so die app ist kostenlos also
einfach herunterladen am gewinnspiel
teilnehmen und mit ein bisschen glück
gehört einer der john ein swatch group
mit ihren männer ihr seht jetzt hier
oben wie viel geld ausgegeben haben ich
hatte nicht vier sondern fünf na klar
wie konnte ich das vergessen das sind
die ganzen schule jetzt kümmere ich mich
um bilder und lahti dann überall hoch es
gibt natürlich auch große gruppen und
communitys die sich nur um kaufen und
wieder verkaufen und den ganzen kram
kümmern verband botanischer gärten ist
so die größte und beste option da werde
ich die sachen einstellen bei ebay
kleinanzeigen und möglicherweise
aufstocken aber da sind die gebühren so
hoch dass sich das glaube ich für mich
nicht lohnt also ich fokussiere mich auf
verband botanischer gärten und auf ebay
kleinanzeigen als allererstes habe ich
mich darum gekümmert wirklich
vernünftige bilder zu machen mit viel
licht das schafft einfach unfassbares
vertrauen wenn die bilder gut sind egal
was sie verkaufen wollt bilder sind die
ps4 damals habe ich komplett
ausgeschnitten und einfach vorne
wirklich komplett weißes bild gesetzt
damit das aussieht als hätte ich die
bilder in einem studio gemacht hier habe
ich die jetzt mit so tiefenunschärfe
einfach auf dem handy gemacht auch wenn
die leute wissen wir der schule aussieht
und so wenn sie sich zwischen zwei oder
drei anzeigen entscheiden werden sie
mitglied das nicht
die besten bilder hat weil das einfach
für für vertrauen sorgen natürlich kommt
es dann auch noch auf sachen an wie
beschreibt man mit denen wie verhandelt
man wie schnell antwortet man und so
weiter aber da kann man wir uns erst
später als nächste stelle ich die auf
allen plattformen das wird
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen arbeit sein
weil es in fünf schuhe und irgendwie
drei verschiedene websites wo ich die
einstellung ich hab mich jetzt noch für
kleider kreisen entschieden also kleiner
kreisel kleinanzeigen und verband
botanischer gärten das mache ich jetzt
und dann schauen wir wie schnell ich die
sachen verkaufen kann so freunde tag
nummer 2 tatsächlich konnten wir den
ersten vier plätzen in 42 schon
verkaufen ich weiß aber nicht mehr zu
welchem preis perfekt 130 euro haben wir
für den schub bekommen ich mache mich
jetzt auf dem weg zur post und bringen
den weg aber heute steht noch eine große
sache an viele paypal-konten
organisieren viele lieferadressen
organisieren so dass sie uns bei jedem
rennen mehrmals eintragen können um
unsere chancen zu erhöhen
und genau das machen wir jetzt hallo
mutter erlösend gebe hallo vater
verlesen
wenn ich deine paypal daten haben kann
ich deine paypal adresse haben kann ich
seine paypal adresse haben kann ich
deine paypal adresse haben willst ja ihr
habt das system wahrscheinlich verstand
ich lass mir jetzt alle paypal und
lieferdaten ganz genau per whatsapp
schicken damit ich die habe und mich
dann mit dem jedes level eintragen kann
ich schätze dass das mehrere stunden
dauern wird weil tatsächlich führt zum
beispiel den job eines mokka unendlich
viele travelstar sind was natürlich
super für uns ist aber dann kostet das
auch eine menge zeit also habe ich
erstmal damit gestartet alle daten in
mein auto fill formular in google chrome
einzutragen so dass ich nicht jedes mal
alle daten neu eintragen muss wenn ich
irgendein google form oder so viel raffl
ausfülle
so spare ich mir ein bisschen zeit aber
ich glaube es wird trotzdem eine menge
arbeit seien diese woche liegt natürlich
der absolute fokus auf dem john 1 mokka
und dem klima dank die am samstag
rauskommen wenn wir davon einen bekommen
dann sind wir quasi safe natürlich mache
ich diese woche auch wieder alles mit
hilfe rufend die dieses video
unterstützen eine komplett kostenlose
app bei der ihr alles nico release dass
alle raffles aufgelistet bekommt die
euch über shops oder unerwartete release
sofort benachrichtigt die direkte
kontakte zu nike und adidas haben die
euch so also immer mit den besten
informationen versorgen können und bei
dem ihr alle sales und aktionen im
fashionbereich aufgelistet bekommt ein
absolutes muss wenn ihr sowas in der
richtung machen wollt track den legendär
video beschreibung und ladet euch die
app unter genau darüber
wenn ich mich jetzt auch in die ganzen
sehr viel zeit wir haben großes glück
bei dem jordan 1 mog hat zum beispiel
gibt es diese woche unendlich viele
releases insgesamt sind das 25 apples in
die wir uns für den job eines mokka
eintragen können mit dem neuen accounts
und neuen paypal-konten neuen
lieferadressen die wir jetzt haben sind
das insgesamt 241 raffl eintragungen die
wir machen können und das nimmt
unendlich viel zeit in anspruch also
kein witz ich habe die ganzen sachen
zwar eingetragen so dass sich die auto
fill mäßig im jura filz eintragen kann
trotz alledem ist es wirklich unendlich
viel aufwand und ich glaube dass der
komplette tag heute darin dafür
draufgehen wird mich in jedes level
einzutragen beim letzten mal hatte ich
glück dieses mal überlasse ich das nicht
dem schicksal von trage mich in 241
mögliche optionen ein um den schuh zu
kaufen beim klima dank der glaube ich
geisteskrank rechte ecke gehen wird der
wirklich im reseller unendlich viel
kosten wird haben wir auch viele
optionen 13 raffles insgesamt mit neuen
account sind das 117 eintragungen im
raffles also insgesamt haben wir
irgendwie 2 141 358 raffl eintragung
wenn wir das alles so hinbekommen
wirklich krass mal sehen ob das
funktioniert und dann habe ich ganz
stumpf erstmal für die nächsten paar
stunden liste für liste für liste
ausgefüllt
so ich bin jetzt dreieinhalb oder vier
stunden dabei ist es unheimlich viel
arbeit ich bin nicht mal zur hälfte
durch zweites problem man muss bei
manchen raffles irgendwelche beiträge
licon oder irgendwelchen insta seiten
folgen ich habe jetzt schon drei alte
account reaktiviert aber es reicht
einfach nicht um für alle teams zu
sorgen das bedeutet ich muss jetzt
beispielsweise meinem bruder bescheid
sagen dass der folgende beiträge zu
leiten hat den irgendwie bei instagram
folgen muss und so weiter es ist
unheimlich viel zu koordinieren es ist
unheimlich viel einzutragen also es ist
wirklich ich weiß nicht ob sich das
lohnt selbst wenn man dafür das nicht er
bekommt also der da muss schon der muss
schon sehr teuer im retail sein damit
sich das in jeder weise orientiert wie
gesagt ich bin jetzt noch nicht mal
durch aber dass es so viel arbeit ist
damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet besser
wäre es dass wir jetzt einen der schuhe
bekommen wenn diese arbeit umsonst war
halleluja und auch weil ich kurz zu
veranschaulichen wie viel das
hoffentlich bringt sich in so viele
raffles einzutragen zeige ich euch das
anhand dieser vierecke die jeweils für
einen raffl entry stehen es gibt drei
personen die alle gerne den schuh kaufen
würden personal treibt sich in ein raffl
ein und hofft darauf den schuh kaufen zu
können
person beträgt sich in alle 24 raffles
einmal ein und person c trägt sich in
jedes der raffles neun mal ein so krass
sehen die unterschiede bildlich aus so
mittlerweile haben wir 23 15 ich habe
die ganze zeit noch weiter gemacht das
ist wirklich viel mehr aufwand als
gedacht two factor authentifizierung von
pepr nimmt mich komplett hobbs ich muss
man die ganze zeit von allen leuten die
mir ihre paypal konten gegeben haben
irgendwelche sms mit bestätigungscode
weiterleiten lassen
also für mich und für die leute von
denen ich die accounts benutze ist
wirklich ein absoluter stress komplette
horror und überhaupt nicht so umsetzbar
für weitere releases also das ist keine
option wie man das weiter machen kann
außer man macht irgendwie two factor aus
und hat zugriff auf die einzelnen
instagram konnten so bringt das auf
jeden fall nichts ich bin froh dass wir
jetzt nahezu durch den parasiten jetzt
noch nicht geklappt aber wir sind uns
irgendwie bei 200 oder so das ist schon
sehr gut meisten raffl sind geschafft
ich lass gut sein für heute und jetzt in
den stream denn ich schrie mir täglich
links in der video beschreibung jetzt
was wir einfach hoffen dass das recht
nächster tag ich habe mich gerade noch
in alle weiteren verbleibenden raffles
eingetragen auch noch in die vom dank
aber das ist natürlich nicht unsere
einzige option morgen kommen die schuhe
auch noch auf vier webseiten mit first
come first served ich male mir keine
besonders großen chancen aus denn die
butter werden natürlich auch dort am
start sein
aber es ist auf jeden fall eine option
die man vor
suchen kann und so können wir uns
vielleicht noch weiter absichern und
vielleicht sind wir schnell genug mit
auto fehlt da irgendwie an einen zur
anzukommen der dank kommt ganz normal
über 1 nicastro also da könnten wir
theoretisch chancen haben aber ich
glaube dass zu begehrt um da irgendwo
dranzukommen
wir hoffen einfach auf die raffles wir
haben getan was wir konnten besser wäre
es dass wir irgendein bekommen nichts
ahnend lege ich mich also schlafen mit
großer vorfreude auf den nächsten tag
großer sicherheit dass wir einen der
schule gekommen werden was passiert ich
wache um 11 uhr auf ja kein scheiß ich
habe tatsächlich einfach vergessen den
wecker zu stellen absolut peinlich und
komplett verdient dass sich dann
zumindest keinen schuh über first come
first serve bekommen habe aber die
raffles bleiben ja noch offen ja
wirklich komplett um und mega verdient
dass ich da keinen schub bekommen habe
jetzt heißt es auf die raffl antworten
warten ich arbeite jetzt erstmal weiter
und dann hoffen wir dass eben eins der
raffles anschlägt doch dann nicht mal
fünf minuten später
ja das ist kein pardon mehr zählen es
hat tatsächlich funktioniert wir haben
ein raffl gewonnen bei sms also sneakers
darf eins der raffles hat bisher
gerettet unfassbar tatsächlich über eine
mail über einen der kaum denn ich mir
von einem kumpel organisiert habe also
ich hätte bis dato keine dafür gewonnen
wenn wir jetzt noch einen sneaker
bekommen sollten also sind noch raffles
offen ich habe schon länger absagen
bekommen aber ein paar der raffl sind
noch offen wenn wir noch einen bekommen
sollten dann wäre es halt wirklich
geisteskrank und werden fettes fettes
profit gemacht aber die meisten raffl
sind schon ausgezählt ich glaube
tatsächlich nicht dass man irgendwas
kommt wir haben kein weiteres raffl mehr
gewonnen aber auch ohne im zweiten
drittel wird mir so langsam wirklich
unangenehm also es fällt mir schwer euch
zu beweisen dass ist realist ich kann
euch den schul jetzt noch nicht zeigen
weil er über die weihnachtsfeiertage
noch nicht kommt oder weil der jetzt
zumindest noch nicht da ist nach den
weihnachtsfeiertagen werdet ihr noch
finster sehen können etwa mit henrys
folgt da gern rein ich hoffe wirklich
dass ich in den nächsten projekten mal
fakt weil ich ja ich nehme für die
weihnachtsfeiertage in der kommenden
woche also für euch jetzt letzte woche
auch mal ein paar tage frei also wenn
dieses video ein bisschen weniger
aufwendig ist als sonst die anderen
nimmt mir das nicht übel ich habe mir
zwei tage frei genommen trotzdem
dailygreen ab dem neuen jahr geht es
wieder mit volker voran am mittwoch
kommt schon das nächste video ein
kleiner jahresrückblick von mir
ich hoffe euch hat das video trotzdem
gefallen
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
jack muss man aus für sneaker und
fashion kam wir sehen uns am mittwoch
couscous kurs dank für den kranken
support